[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to what's next
the data scientist and data analyst
my name is Jun Yang VP of cloud AI
industry Solutions and I'm sudhir
husband I'm senior director of product
management for data analytics at Google
Cloud
AI is here and it's growing fast every
day I have so many interesting
conversations with our customers about
the opportunity of innovation with data
and AI absolutely AI is top of mind for
all our data Cloud customers and we have
some amazing announcements to talk to
you about today so let's get started
the promise of data AI is undeniable and
it's a reality today for many
organizations
AI advances are happening faster than
most people realize it is a
groundbreaking era for AI the last few
years have led us to a Tipping Point
with AI adoption where we have seen the
impact of AI across more and more
organizations and more and more use
cases
organizations for many Industries and
varying level of ml expertise are
solving business critical problems with
AI from creating compelling customer
experience to optimizing operations to
automating routine tasks these
organizations learn to innovate faster
and ultimately get ahead in the
marketplace
but how do they get there AI is hard
fundamentally hard
first challenge start with data it is
the challenge to manage this growth and
complexity it is a challenge to prepare
data for AI and ml usage second AI
expertise is scarce how many AI experts
do you need to get your first model into
production what about the next set of
use cases
and finally if you have all the pieces
in place the road from prototype to
production can still take months if not
years
how can you scale faster with confidence
we have learned from Google's years of
experience in AI development and how to
make the data to AI Journey as seamless
as possible and we have poured this
experience into our product and services
in today's session we'll walk through
how our data clouds simplify the way our
teams who can work with data built-in Ai
and ml expertise and capabilities
designed to meet users where they are
with their current skills and finally
with our infrastructure governance and
Emma Ops capability help organization to
leverage AI at scale
and now let me hand it over to sedir to
share more about data cloud and how to
overcome these challenges thank you June
let's talk about the first challenge you
brought up data complexity the problem
is unpredictable nature of data data
comes in all shapes and forms speeds and
sources its structured semi-structured
and unstructured mostly it's ingested in
batch today but it is increasingly
required to be transformed and utilized
in real time for real-time decision
making if you're not already there soon
your company will find itself in a
center of multi-cloud multi-format and
multi-source data ecosystem an ecosystem
that frankly the monolithic and
expensive architectures of the past is
not built for
we have designed our data Cloud to meet
your needs of today and tomorrow with
our data Cloud you gain a complete and
unified data and AI solution so you can
manage each stage of data life cycle
from operational data to analytical and
intelligent applications
with our data Cloud Ai and machine
learning comes built in
helping you make full use of your data
to improve insights and automate Core
Business processes that's why today I'm
proud to announce the general
availability of big lake to help you
break the data silos and unify your data
lakes and warehouses Big Lake will also
support Apache Iceberg which is becoming
the standard for open source table
formats for your data leaks and soon we
will also add support for other formats
like Delta Lake and hoodie our built-in
support for Apache spark in bigquery
will allow data practitioners to create
bigquery stored procedures unifying
their work in spark
with their SQL Pipelines
this open data ecosystem is at the heart
of our strategy as of today over 800
software Partners power their
applications using our data cloud and 40
data platform Partners like DBT data IQ
and Tableau support bigquery through
certified Integrations
and customer adoption continues to grow
fueled by the ecosystem initiatives like
data Cloud Alliance
now we know
80 to 90 percent of data you have today
is unstructured this includes your
images your video files your audio files
today we are announcing support for
unstructured data in bigquery through
object tables object tables enable you
to take advantage of common security and
governance across your data you can now
build data products that unify
structured and unstructured data in
bigquery
this makes bigquery One-Stop solution to
store manage and process all types of
data at global scale
one example of a company making their
data work for them is ANZ Bank the
second largest bank in Australia ANZ
uses Google Cloud to help customers make
better decisions by analyzing aggregate
data sets and delivering powerful
insights to create personalized customer
experiences
manual operations that used to take days
now only take seconds
so in a nutshell to overcome data
complexity challenges we are bringing
lakes and warehouses together with big
lake and providing support for open
formats we are unifying structured
semi-structured and unstructured data
workloads into bigquery
openness unification and Trust are the
foundation of intelligent data-driven
organization and with that I will turn
it over to you June to talk about what
we are doing about the about AI skills
Gap in the industry yeah first of all
thank you sudhir and it's so great to
see the amazing progress our teams have
made here
now let's talk about harnessing the
power of AI despite the skill Gap
challenge according to U.S Bureau of
Labor Statistics data scientist is the
number six fastest growing job in the
U.S and it raises on to higher this is
the challenge for organizations that are
looking to apply AI across their
businesses
Google Cloud addresses this challenge
head on by offering a wide range of
capabilities that can increase the reach
of AIML to more users and help your
scarce resource your data scientists to
achieve greater productivity
organizations can start with our
out-of-box API like translation
transcription and many more where
developers can directly apply Google's
state-of-the-art AI to quickly solve
real world problems without the need to
build AI models themselves when you want
to work with your own data to build
custom models vertex AI offer a range of
ml tools to help you to build deploy and
manage ml models
this includes the ability to start from
scratch to create a fully custom models
were built on top of or one of our
existing models and then fine-tune them
for your particular needs starting with
bigquery ML a SQL interface that unlocks
ml capability for data analysts and
simple ways to be able to build and
train their models
as you have heard from sudir bigquery
will support unstructured data which
means bigquery ml would also work with
unstructured data you can now bring your
own model or use a model that's
pre-trained by Google directly on
bigquery object tables the results can
be stored and managed in bigquery for
further analysis or deplorative vertex
AI for real-time prediction
the next training capability is automl
people can create custom models quickly
with their own data and with minimum
data science expertise
more and more
we are seeing that even expert data
scientists want to start with the base
automl generated model then fine-tune it
to achieve greater accuracy with their
own data
automl provides Advanced models trained
by Google as a jumping off point for
customization
Seagate a partner for Google's data
center
and uses machine learning to predict
recurring disk drive failures with
automl they're able to achieve a
Precision of 98 percent
that's as far far more than the 70 to 80
percent achieved with a custom model
for users who want more control over ml
we recently announced exciting
announcement for automl workflows which
allows you selectively modify each step
in the model building and the deployment
process and be able to tweak custom
tweaks for for your automl and giving
you a more control working with automl
we will start with structured data and
expand support to unstructured data in
the coming months
tapnet is a powerful algorithm developed
by Google researchers that leverage
neural nets for tabular data today we're
adding tabnet to workflow to make it
easier for organization to work at a
massive scale without sacrificing the
explainability or accuracy
and finally custom Training which
provide the most flexibility data
scientists and MX first can work with
their familiar open source Frameworks to
be able to build trade deploy and
monitor ml models five times faster with
vertex AI
for some workloads faster is what it's
all about
I am excited to introduce vertex AI
Vision a revolutionary end-to-end
computer vision application development
service
that helps you to be able to reduce the
amount of time it takes to build
computer vision application from days to
minutes at a fraction of the cost was it
easy to use drag and drop interface and
pre-trained model for common tasks
vertex AI vision is the One-Stop shop to
build deploy manage computer vision
application
from ingestion to analysis to storage
now you can easily create computer
vision application for any business need
from Inventory management in retail to
improving safety in the plant workers
for in manufacturing even traffic
Management in large cities plain sight
is a leading provider of computer vision
application and solutions and early
adopter of vertex AI vision
with a speed and cost efficiency benefit
plainside is already developing new
application and revenue streams that
were previously not viable
at Google our goal is to make our
products that are truly helpful to
everyone whether it's solving big
problems or providing assistance in
everyday life
AI has already had a profound impact in
our lives and there's even more greater
potential to come
this opportunities also comes with a
deep sense of responsibility to build
for AI for the common good
AI that benefits all people in society
we prioritize the responsible
development of AI this includes testing
to mitigate bias prioritizing
responsible use in the product design
providing transparency and developer
education we apply responsible AI to all
of our products we're committed to
iterating and improving and will
continue to incorporate the best
practices and Lessons Learned into the
products we build
you have just seen a variety of
capabilities in vertex AI to develop
AIML models we realize that one size
doesn't fit all we want to offer
organization their choice to pick the
best tool for the job at hand putting
powerful ml capability in the hands of
more people and helping data scientists
to build models faster means you can do
more with your data
and to be able to feel the data-driven
transformation
in June it's amazing when you go out and
make technology accessible to more users
the kinds of results they can get and
especially AIML from a technology
perspective
but the next challenge for organizations
with data and AI enhance of more users
is how do you scale with confidence
Vodafone one of the large largest
telecommunications company in the world
made a huge leap forward with its AI
capabilities first they unified all of
their data into a single data ocean in
bigquery establishing a single source of
Truth and making data accessible across
the organization
this Unleashed a huge number of use
cases and increased demand for AIML
capabilities so next they built AI
booster an internal ml platform powered
by vertex AI now their AI development is
80 percent faster and more cost
effective all without compromising
governance and reliability
so how did they get there scaling data
and AI across an organization first
requires strong data governance and
management and secondly in order to move
from data to AI efficiently across use
cases organizations also need to
streamline end-to-end processes from
preparing data to building deploying and
maintaining machine learning models
let's start with unified governance
of data Cloud provides customers with an
end-to-end data management and
governance layer with built-in
intelligence to help enable trust and
data and accelerate time to Insight
to further these capabilities we are
announcing various Innovations to
dataplex our intelligent data fabric
dataplex helps organizations centrally
manage and govern distributed data today
we are introducing
data lineage so you can get complete
end-to-end lineage from ingestion of
data to analysis to machine learning
models data quality will enable you to
gain confidence in your data which is
critical to get accurate predictions and
more importantly dataplex is now fully
integrated with big league so you can
now manage fine-grained access across
the organization at scale
vertex AI Integrations across our data
Cloud streamline access to data all the
way from prototyping to production
this brings me to the centralized ml Ops
capabilities in vertex AI no matter how
you train your model our platform can
register deploy and manage it throughout
its entire life cycle vertex AI model
registry is now ga
providing a unified repository for all
models to help Version Control label
metadata and easily deploying for both
batch and online predictions vertex AI
pipelines takes ml Ops to the next level
with serverless orchestration and
automation of your ml workflows
pre-built pipeline components are
available across data sources like data
proc data flow and training capabilities
include automl as well as bigquery ml
and to maintain model performance model
monitoring and explainable AI
capabilities help you detect skew and
interpret predictions
we recently announced example based
explanations which help you mitigate
data challenges such as mislabeled
examples so you can quickly identify
problems and improve model performance
Walmart's incredible digital
transformation Journey illustrates
what's possible for organizations that
choose our data cloud
Walmart's migration to bigquery and
Adoption of vertex AI has enabled them
to unleash the potential of AI across
the entire business from predicting
demand to managing in-stock inventories
to optimizing supply chain to freeing up
Associates to focus more on customers
and serving customers
in one case they were able to optimize
processes and save 10 million dollars of
food waste every week
I love Walmart's Journey
thank you Sadir it is so great to see so
many great customer stories and so many
exciting product announcements to learn
more we have many amazing sessions for
you and invite you to watch all of them
here are our top sessions
and for something fun for those of you
looking to get your hands on we're
partnering with the Drone Racing League
to bring you new immersive learning
experience visit
drl.io Google Cloud to learn how you can
work with the data to be able to predict
rates outcome and provide tips to
enhance pilot performances
we hope you have enjoyed this session
thank you so much for attending and we
hope to see you soon bye-bye thank you
[Music]